bonjour je vais vous dévoiler les
techniques les plus efficaces utilisée
par les grands manipulateurs
certaines de ces techniques ont une
efficacité redoutable
elle se base sur les plus récentes
recherches scientifiques sur le cerveau
certaines utilisent les technologies de
la communication est plus avancée pour
nous influencer sans même que l'on en
soit conscient elles sont pas très
connus et pourtant elles sont utilisées
dans une multitude de domaines on les
retrouve sur internet
elles sont utilisées par des leaders
politiques elles sont utilisées par des
publicitaires elles sont utilisées par
des célèbres influenceurs sur les
réseaux sociaux on en retrouve même si
dans le comportement de certains grands
séducteurs
je vais vous expliquer ces techniques et
je vous expliquerai également comment
les déjouer comment retrouver plus de
liberté pour soi mais également pour une
vie plus intéressante ou démocratiques
dans notre société
la première technique et celle de
limitation la logique est la suivante le
manipulateur va étudier rapidement le
comportement de la personne avec
laquelle il est en train de parler puis
ensuite tel un miroir il va se mettre à
l'imiter il va imiter son comportement
essentiellement non verbale
les recherches scientifiques montrent
que ça fonctionne ça fonctionne dans
deux cas premier cas lorsque le
manipulateur va reprendre le même
vocabulaire les mêmes mots que la
personne avec laquelle il s'entraîne
parler bien sûr faut pas que ça se
remarque sinon ça fait l'effet inverse
et deuxième cas lorsque il va reproduire
la même gestuelle par exemple les mêmes
mimiques faciales ou le même type de
geste que la personne avec laquelle il
est en train de parler bien sûr si la
personne leur père ça fait l'effet
inverse
il faut également qui est un petit
décalage de quelques secondes entre le
moment où ils repèrent la technique et
moment où il l'a refait il ya des
validation scientifique par exemple dans
une recherche scientifique
on a demandé à des serveurs dans un bar
de bien vouloir répéter les mêmes mots
que son client lorsqu'il s'adresse à lui
et bien quand il le fait
et ça augmente considérablement le
montant des pourboires que le client
laisse ensuite
l'expérimentation a été refait également
dans un magasin d'électroménager
on a demandé au vendeur de récupérer le
même vocabulaire que son client par
exemple à vous voulez acheter un
ordinateur pour votre fils qu'ils soient
de bons rapports qualité prix mais pas
trop cher pour lui offrir à noël et bien
non seulement le client achète beaucoup
plus facilement
l'ordinateur qui est montrée par le
vendeur mais en plus de ça le vendeur va
être perçu comme étant plus compétents
et plus agréable alors comment ça
fonctionne au niveau du cerveau les
chercheurs ont démontré que nous avons
au niveau de notre cerveau des neurones
qui s'appelle les neurones miroirs
ce sont ce type de neuro qui lorsque
vous êtes face à quelqu'un qui bâille
ça vous donne aussi envie de bâiller
lorsque vous êtes face à quelqu'un qui
rit aux éclats
ça vous donne aussi envie de rien eh
bien on s'est rendu compte que quand on
est face à quelqu'un que l'on apprécié
que l'on aime on a tendance à reproduire
également sa gestuelle à reproduire son
vocabulaire sans même en avoir
conscience
mais on s'est rendu compte aussi que
lorsque quelqu'un en face de nous
reproduire notre vocabulaire reproduit
nos gestes sans qu'on s'en rende compte
eh bien on a tendance à davantage
l'apprécier on est attiré par cette
personne les manipulateurs le savent et
donc utilisent cette technique pour ce
faire davantage apprécié la deuxième
technique de manipulation
c'est une technique qui s'appelle le
toucher n'avez vous jamais remarqué que
les hommes politiques quand il serre la
main de quelqu'un déjà ils le font de
façon très chaleureuse
mais souvent il met l'autre main sur
l'avant bras ou sur le bras de la
personne qui salue pour quoi faire
déjà ça donne une image de l'homme
politique comme étant plus chaleureux
mais ya pas que ça on a reproduit
l'expérimentation scientifique suivante
imaginez la scène ça se passe un arrêt
de bus et un étudiant va voir d'autres
étudiants qu'il ne connaît pas et il
explique qu'il a oublié son
retenez et sa carte bancaire qui ne peut
donc pas payer un ticket de bus et il
demande aux étudiants s'ils veulent bien
le dépanner lui donner la somme
correspondant bien sûr cet effet sur un
grand nombre d'étudiants et l'étudiant
en question ne connais pas les autres
étudiants et ici il a deux options
premières options soit il fait sa
demande tel quel
deuxième option il fait sa demande mais
pendant qu'il est en train de parler il
va se mettre pendant deux trois secondes
à peine à toucher l'avant bras ou le
bras de l'étudiant et qui parle
eh bien figurez vous que quand il fait
ce type de comportement ça augmente la
probabilité que l'étudiant donne la
somme par deux voire par trois
cette expérimentation a été reproduit
dans un bar et de nouveau on a demandé
au serveur de bien vouloir s'adresser
aux clients en au bout de quelques
minutes le touchant soit au niveau de
l'avant-bras soit au niveau du bras est
ici de nouveau sur un durée très courte
et bien le montant des pourboires est
significativement plus élevées elles ne
fonctionnent pas cannes est l'argent on
sait que les psychologues quand ils
touchent leurs patients ça fait en sorte
que leurs patients se confie davantage
de même dans les avions
on a fait des excuses des
expérimentations avec des hôtels c'est
quand on goûte quelques minutes
l'hôtesse de l'air touche le passager 20
le passager la sent comme étant bien
plus proche de lui il apprécie davantage
c'est sûr qu'avec l'épidémie de covin et
les gestes barrières les manipulateurs
doit vraiment être embêtés avec cette
technique ici du touch est bon mais
c'est pas plus mal
troisième technique celle ci s'appelle
le pied dans la porte
imaginons que vous deviez demander à
quelqu'un qu'il vous prête 100 euros
vous avez deux possibilités
première possibilité vous demandez la
somme 100 euros deuxième possibilité
vous l'a demandé en deux temps c'est la
technique du pied d'un apporte d'abord
vous demander un petit comportement une
petite somme est ce que tu accepterais
ou est-ce que vous accepteriez de me
donner 10 euros et puis une fois que la
personne vous a donné 10 euros vous
demandez 90 euros 2
au total on fonctionne en deux temps
d'abord une petite demande qui est le
pied dans la porte puis une plus grosse
demande vous multiplier par deux voire
par trois la probabilité que
effectivement la personne vous donne la
somme
cette technique fonctionne pas
uniquement dans ce contexte là ça
fonctionne également dans des contextes
qui sont plus généraux écouter cette
expérience très intéressante elle a été
faite au canada
c'est une femme qui travaille pour une
association de lutte contre le cancer
elle fait du porte à porte et elle
explique aux personnes qui ouvre que
d'ici quelques jours il va y avoir une
collecte de fonds pour son association
mais d'abord elle demande et c'est le
premier acte du pied dans la porte
elle demande aux personnes de bien
vouloir porter sur le revers de leur
veste
une petit jean qui jaune la plupart des
gens acceptent quelques jours plus tard
une deuxième personne vient se présenter
ce coup ci pour obtenir les dos et bien
les statistiques montrent que toutes les
personnes qui avaient mis ici cette
petite fleur sur le revers de leur veste
et bien donne un don qui est bien
supérieur aux par rapport aux personnes
qui n'ont pas mis cette petite fleur
gens n'ont pas fait l'objet du pied dans
la porte
le dont il est quasiment trois fois
supérieur on sait considérable quatrième
technique
alors cette quatrième technique elle est
un peu différente c'est la technique qui
s'appelle vous êtes libres 2 le
manipulateur fait sa demande mais il
rajoute à la fin une petite phrase qui
est mais tu es libre de faire le
comportement ou non tu es libre vous
êtes libre de me donner ou pas autrement
dit cette petite phrase qui rajoutait la
fin c'est une petite phrase quasi
magique qui multiplie considérablement
la probabilité que la personne face
l'acte bien sûr il ya eu dès validation
scientifique
l'expérimentation est la suivante on
reprend l'expérimentation de l'étudiant
qui a oublié ou qui dit avoir oublié de
son porte monnaie un arrêt de bus et il
va avoir tout un tas d'autres étudiants
qui nous connaît toujours pas avec deux
possibilités soit il fait la demande
telle qu'elle soit sur un autre type
d'étudiant il fait la demande mais il
rajoute tout simple
à la fin mais tu es libre où vous êtes
libre de me donner la somme pas eh bien
les étudiants à qui on a dit vous êtes
libre de le faire ou pas sont cinq fois
plus nombreux a effectivement donné la
somme en question pour ses considérables
aussi alors peut-être connaissez-vous
dans les techniques que je viens de vous
donner les techniques que certaines
personnes de votre entourage utilise sur
vous il ya des manipulateurs partout ou
peut-être est-ce vous qui les utilisent
et sur les autres sait-on jamais 5e
technique
ici c'est pas une technique est utilisée
par certaines personnes mais c'est une
technique qui est beaucoup plus générale
beaucoup plus globale c'est la technique
de la manipulation de la publicité
on a fait l'expérimentation dans notre
laboratoire pour essayer de voir si la
publicité agissez sans en avoir
conscience
alors vous allez me dire bah moi la
publicité sur internet je la regarde
même pas dans quelle peut pas agir sur
moi eh bien vous vous trompez on a fait
l'expérimentation suivante dans notre
laboratoire
on a demandé un très grand nombre de
personnes de bien vouloir regarder sur
un écran d'ordinateur le centre de
l'écran de lire un texte de façon très
concentrée au centre et pendant ce temps
là on a mis en eau d'écran des
publicités on a contrôlé par une caméra
qui enregistre le mouvement des yeux que
jamais les personnes ne voient ces
publicités de manière consciente jamais
il les regarde et d'ailleurs pour leur a
posé la question est-ce que vous avez vu
des publicités les gens dits non j'étais
concentré sur le centre de l'écran j'ai
pas vu du tout ces publicités par contre
quand on retrouve ces gens une semaine
après et quand on leur montre les
marques bien sûr elle s'en souviennent
pas parce qu'elles n'ont pas vu les
publicités mais elles sont davantage
attirés par les marques et elles ont
envie de les acheter
elles sont séduites par ces marques
quand on leur demande pourquoi les
personnes ne savent pas on est ici très
proche d'une influence subliminale de la
publicité
on s'est posé la question aussi est-ce
que lorsqu'on regarde ce coup-ci de
publicité mais on la regarde très vite
est ce qu'il ya un impact quand même
alors vous allez me dire - les
publicités s'agit pas sur moi parce que
je les regarde très vite
mais aussitôt entraperçu aussitôt oublié
eh bien vous vous trompez de nouveau
puisque on a fait une expérimentation où
on a demandé à des gens de regarder les
publicités pendant deux trois secondes à
peine aussitôt entraperçu aussitôt
oublié puis effectivement les gens
oublient très vite la publicité sauf que
quand on retrouve ces gens trois mois
plus tard je dis bien trois mois et
quand leur ronde entre les marques
bien sûr ils s'en souviennent plus mais
leur cerveaux s'en souvient leur cerveau
s'en souvient et de nouveau ils ont
davantage envie d'acheter ses marques
il ya ici une influence qui dure jusqu'à
trois mois on s'est posé la question est
ce que les enfants et les préadolescents
ne serait pas également sous influence
de cette publicité non conscient donc on
a reproduit dans notre laboratoire de
nouveau des expérimentations sur des
enfants et des préadolescents et on a
montré effectivement que sur internet
par exemple les enfants qui ont été
soumis à des messages publicitaires qui
ont très vite été également oublié de
trois secondes
eh bien ces enfants là ne sont
absolument pas conscients de l'impact
et pourtant il ya un impact c'est à dire
qu'ils sont davantage attirés par les
marques
une semaine après et ils ont envie de
les acheter alors ici ça pose un vrai
problème c'est que on sait que la
majorité des publicités qui sont vus
notamment à la télévision par les
enfants sont des publicités pour des
produits de mauvaise qualité
nutritionnelle pour la malbouffe en gros
bonbon chocolat face fou de boissons
trop sucrées et on sait également qu'il
ya un lien entre ce type de publicité et
le surpoids et l'obésité c'était
démontrer scientifiquement il ya même un
chercheur américain qui a montré que
près d'un tiers des enfants obèses ne
l'auraient pas été s'il n'avait pas été
soumis notamment la télévision à des
publicités pour de la malbouffe
donc c'est considérable ici l'avantagent
de ce type de recherche c'est que ça
permet aussi de prendre conscience des
techniques de manipulation
par exemple on sait que les publicités
pour les enfants vont enrobé la marque
dans des émotions positives par exemple
ils vont
ont utilisé des publicités sous forme de
dessins animés et le cerveau de l'enfant
va mémoriser la marque enrobés dans des
émotions positives telles marques
c'est la reine des neiges telle marque
est utilisé par telle célébrité tel
sportif que j'adore et le cerveau de
l'enfant
il n'est pas capable de lutter contre
cette manipulation qui est une véritable
manipulation du type conditionnement
c'est une manipulation par les émotions
ici leur cerveau n'est pas capable de
résister je vais vous confier quelque
chose ça fait 25 ans que je travaille
sur ces techniques d'influencé de la
publicité et je peux vous dire que c'est
ce sont des techniques qui ont une
influence considérable
ça fait quelques années que je me bats
pour qu'il y ait en france une
interdiction de la publicité pour la
malbouffe pour des produits de très
mauvaise qualité nutritionnelle auprès
des enfants
et si on parvenait à supprimer la
publicité pour la malbouffe ne serait ce
qu'à la télévision la journée vous parle
pas du soir juste la journée eh bien on
diminuerait le nombre d'enfants en
surpoids ou obèses de près de 60000 donc
ça c'est important
je crois qu'il est temps de prendre
vraiment la santé de nos enfants en main
et de faire en sorte que cette
manipulation par la publicité elle les
lieux le moins souvent possible
alors si on fait un petit bilan de ce
que je vous ai raconté jusqu'à présent
et si on reprend l'ensemble de ces
techniques de manipulation comment
lutter contre déjà premier point il faut
bien les connaître et surtout deuxième
point il faut arriver à les reconnaître
au moment où le manipulateur les
utilisent parce que si on met un peu de
conscience dans ces techniques qui ont
une influence non consciente et bien ça
diminue considérablement l'efficacité de
ces techniques de manipulation donc il
faut mettre du conscient lorsque ces
techniques sont utilisées
concernant la publicité il faut au
moment de l'achat se fixer des règles
très précises
si vous ne fixez pas de règles il ya une
probabilité assez grande pour que vous
achetiez des publicités des produits
dont
les publicités on the agit sur vous à un
niveau relativement non conscient donc
ici il faut se fixer des règles très
précises par exemple j'achète le
meilleur rapport qualité prix
j'achète le produit qui est le meilleur
pour l'environnement
pour la santé et à prendre ces règles
aux enfants et dans ces cas-là vous
diminuer considérablement la probabilité
que la publicité agissent sur vous à un
niveau dont conscient bon au final
évidemment il faut pas penser qu'il ya
des manipulateurs partout autour de nous
mais il y en a bien plus qu'on imagine
et parfois même aux endroits où on les
attend pas et là vous êtes libre ou non
de me croire